yep that's alex rodriguez grabbing
dinner in los angeles just mere hours
after the world found out jlo got
hitched
you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
on saturday jennifer lopez and ben
affleck made it wedding ring official in
an intimate ceremony at las vegas little
white chapel the eye dues come after the
couple broke off their first engagement
in 2004 but then rekindled their love in
2021 following jlo split from a-rod fast
forward to sunday the same day news
broke that jen and ben tied the knot
alex spent the evening having food at mr
chow with former baseball pro david
ortiz in beverly hills after dinner he
was seen chatting and laughing with
friends i'm at a point in my life that
i'm actually doing all the things i love
to do as far as how the former yankee
star feels about jlo now well here's
what he recently told martha stewart
look we had a great time here's what i
will tell you about jennifer and i was
telling some of my colleagues here the
other day
she's the most talented human being i've
ever been around
hardest worker
and i think
she is
the greatest performer live performer
in the world today when it comes to jen
a source tells e.t she doesn't really
think of him saying quote jen is focused
on herself and doesn't even think twice
about a-rod or his current love life
moving on to ben's eggs jennifer garner
we know what she was doing while benefit
was exchanging vows over the weekend the
actress shared this selfie on instagram
looking carefree while biking along the
coast in lake tahoe california and here
she is taking in the ocean views and
flying high on a paragliding adventure
garner wed affleck in 2005 just one year
after he called off his engagement to
jlo they welcomed three kids together
violet seraphina and samuel before
finalizing their divorce in 2018.
but now we can officially say there is a
new mrs affleck jlo confirmed the
wedding news posting a makeup free pick
from bed and showing off her new wedding
van she also detailed the big day in her
newsletter on the jlo
the singer rocked two gowns one stunning
off-the-shoulder long-sleeved lace gown
by zhuhair murad and another dress from
a past movie
you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
during the ceremony jennifer and ben
exchanged vows as they were surrounded
by their closest friends and family
and the blushing bride signed off her
newsletter writing quote with love mrs
jennifer lynn affleck it's just a dream
come true
[Music]
you